cartoons TV shows and movies sometimes
get so popular they inspire a bunch of
other shows but sometimes they take it
just a little bit too far
stay tuned to hear about a knockoff from
a Disney classic we all loved as kids
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to the things now let's
check out ten knockoffs of popular kid
shows from around the world Guildford
gals okay this one is a pretty weird one
but since plenty of nineties kids and
teenagers watched Gilmore Girls we just
had to add it in it's one of the few
shows on our list that's actually from
the good old USA and it's so exclusive
you'll actually want to see it just to
see what it's like let's be honest
Gilmore Girls was an iconic show every
90s kid grew up on but it looks like it
inspired a sneaky ripoff show that
actually existed somewhere in the USA
more specifically at Hannaford
supermarkets in new england obviously
they had to be sneaky about it it's
definitely not as witty and relatable as
Gilmore Girls but apparently it was a
pretty good drama
it featured Amy and Evie Gilford a
mother-daughter duo that were actually a
mother and daughter in real life they're
played by Laura and Lindsey Glen Cooper
or should we say were played because
there's not a lot of information that
could be found about this show since we
have a feeling Hannaford supermarkets
caught in a lot of trouble for it
or maybe they didn't after all
considering it still a well-written
drama even though it's a clear Gilmore
Girls knockoff but nobody can replace
the quirky original The Legend of lucky
pie this one comes from China and we
have a feeling you'll quickly be able to
tell which show the legend of lucky pie
actually rips off it was produced by a
group of Chinese artists that managed to
make it come to life without any funding
or studio environment which is pretty
impressive after the first short
animation was released in 2015 this
series got fully funded through patreon
but that's when people also started
realizing that it looks strangely
similar to Adventure Time the show
follows The Adventures of lucky and PI
and the majority of the characters have
the exact same eyes as the Adventure
Time characters do many of the
characters pretty much look the same too
even some of the lessons the characters
teach their viewers are similar to
Adventure Time but there seems to be no
real beef between the creators of the
two see
because Stephen Wolford one of the
storyboard artists on the original show
said it's still pretty cute for a
knockoff it's been described as a
cheerful cartoon
although the animation itself was
criticized considering this knockoff
originally had zero budget but still
managed to make people talk about it we
say it's definitely a success dog Aman's
next one comes from Brazil and just by
the name you can probably guess which TV
show it resembles even though Digimon
already got a lot of critique for being
a slight knockoff of Pokemon doggie Mons
takes it to a new level the project was
originally produced by the independent
studio and in a matter of four years the
producer managed to finish one episode
and leave to others unfinished this
story focuses on a twelve-year-old boy
called Alex who finds a mysterious diary
written by a professor the diary holds
some secrets Alex wants to resolve so he
flies to Rio de Janeiro where he meets
his cousins as their quest continues
they enter a portal that transfers them
to a planet of dog Aman's where they
meet digimon like characters that
resemble dogs these doglike creatures
also have the power to transform into
another creature some of the dog Aman's
include be dogs drag dogs green dogs and
so on needless to say that if you're a
dog lover you'll absolutely love this
show too bad it only has one episode
though that three friends are then on a
quest to find the professor that wrote
the mysterious diary as they believe he
could bring them back home to be honest
this sounds like it could be a pretty
good show
tattooed teenage alien fighters from
Beverly Hills now
this one's just hilarious it also comes
from the good ol USA and seriously the
title is just way over the top it dates
back to 1994 but the story suspiciously
resembles Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
and Power Rangers at the same time the
show aired in 1994 in an attempt to be
as big as the Power Rangers but of
course things weren't as peachy for this
long titled show this storyline follows
two teenagers that are able to transform
into giant superheroes they're there to
stop an emperor that wants to take over
the earth and then dominate the universe
one of their amazing superpowers are
their tattoos that flashed to alert when
ever the evil is moving actually now
that we think about it this could also
relate to Harry Potter even though the
first book didn't come out until 1998 in
the US but back to these tattooed aliens
they're known as Laurie Gordon drew and
Swinton and each of them have unique
personalities and talents that are
essential to the team they all have
their own individual weapons and they
each transform into an impressive
superhero oh and also their mentor was a
houseplant we're telling you the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles storyline is
somewhere in there to believe when
gravity falls fans first caught a
glimpse of the totter Stan show the Lea
a lot of questions were raised sure no
one was happy that gravity falls ended
but none of us were really ready to jump
the ship at any possible knockoff just
yet
the show starts with Willy the main
protagonist that gets sent to the
Republic of Tatarstan to learn more
about the totter
language which by the way is not the
same as Russian language the kid is not
supposed to come home until he learns
the totter language it features similar
characters and you can clearly see soos
in the grandma Wendy in the siren and
uncle Stan in the tree version of this
knockoff you can even find Mabel the
animation the characters the story it's
all too similar to gravity falls and
fans definitely took a notice but not
only fans even the creator of gravity
falls Alex Hirsch was aware that this
was a clear copyright infringement of
the original show no one's sure what's
been done since then but the Russian
version is now extremely hard to find so
yes this was indeed a confirmed knockoff
that seemed to have a pretty big
consequence Hawk this layer there can
only be one Slayer out there and her
name is Buffy but this UK show isn't
even a Buffy the Vampire Slayer ripoff
this story has plenty of elements that
tie it to Star Wars even though this
could be a never-ending debate between
the fans hawk the Slayer is actually
just a movie that's been released back
in the 1980s but there seems to be a few
notable similarities to Star Wars
one of the biggest knockoffs people seem
to point out is of course the magical
flying sword also known as the power not
quite like the lightsaber but definitely
similar and then there are the elk and
the door
which looks strangely similar to c-3po
and r2d2 of course the promo poster for
hawk de Slayer also pretty much resemble
Star Wars volt and star clothing also
looks like Darth Vader's as well as the
mask that belonged to the Phantom of the
Opera the movie itself wasn't that bad
and was pretty well received but of
course the resemblance is uncanny we're
still not over that whole Buffy the
Vampire Slayer title resemblance but we
really do recommend watching this movie
if for nothing else for the old-school
filmography which is just absolutely
brilliant yokai watch when yokai watch
first came out a lot of people accused
it of being pretty similar to Pokemon
admittedly since Pokemon was so popular
a lot of shows and games wanted to use
the same concept but very few got away
with it for example Digimon was also
considered a Pokemon knockoff yokai
watch aired in 2014
long after Pokemon was already
established but the characters are still
very similar to the creatures we loved
in Pokemon but in a huge plot twist the
so called knockoff actually became
really popular in Japan and it was
surpassing Pokemon in TV ratings the
franchise released an enemy series along
with a game and four movies but if you
look at the characters it's very clear
where yokai watch got its inspiration
we're pretty sure you can find
similarities with just about any Pokemon
character there is although we have to
say that coming up with brand new
creatures is probably extremely hard
so similarities are kind of expected but
since the franchise became quite
successful it's actually excused from
having the title of a Pokemon knockoff
personally
we still prefer Pokemon although we can
imagine kids today really going for
yokai watch as it's definitely more
relatable Sunday School Musical while
this is not a show it's still so
shocking we just have to include it in
the video and the production team really
did put on a brave show by even daring
to create something remotely similar to
High School Musical the title alone also
makes us think of The Breakfast Club
this mock Buster has a similar title and
a similar promo poster but the actual
storyline is pretty different the story
talks about teens that
go to church when they realized that the
church could be closed because of the
lack of funds the teens take it upon
themselves to raise money by entering a
song and dance competition the group is
led by a talented performer and because
of it they win a cash prize that
eventually saves the church we can
actually think of a few movies that are
quite similar to this including the 2003
movie honey that addressed almost
similar issues but is the 2008 Sunday
School Musical worth watching well based
on the Internet Movie Database ratings
no because it definitely didn't get kind
user reviews but if you need a story
that won't go over your head you should
definitely give this a go however it
could never be as iconic as High School
Musical chop kick Panda we're adding
this one in because Kung Fu Panda was
also a TV series and apparently it
inspired a brand new animation that
actually started at the same time as
Kung Fu Panda legend of Awesomeness but
only one of those was well-received chop
kick Panda just didn't sit well with a
lot of viewers this ripoff belongs to
Canada and the storyline pretty much
matches Kung Fu Panda it talks about a
fat and incredibly lazy panda called
Zeebo who wants to become the master of
martial arts of course he can't get
there because he's just a dojo cleaner
but when an evil tiger wants to take
over the kingdom
Zeebo takes it upon himself to stop him
by training as hard as possible does he
win well you'll have to watch the movie
to find out it's worth noting that this
is not the only country Panda ripoff as
critics also corny to Brazil's little
panda fighter that was also exactly the
same sorry folks there can only be one
awesome katha out there and his name is
Pope if you love the original movie be
ready to have strong thoughts about chop
kick Panda but we still have to give
them props for being so brave to release
the movie well just you wait
you'd never think Tom and Jerry could
get ripped off but it actually did sort
of well just you wait is an old Russian
cartoon that follows the adventure of a
wolf that's trying to catch a rabbit the
animations don't really feature any
dialogue and are full of instrumentals
just like Tom and Jerry just like Jerry
the wolf's plans also always fail but at
least it makes for a good episode the
series was pretty successful
and are still watched in Russia today
but after the 1990s more and more people
started noticing the similarities
between the wolf and the hare and our
favorite cat and mouse duo after being
confronted the director actually
admitted he borrowed a lot of
inspiration from Disney but he claims he
didn't even see Tom and Jerry until way
after the first while Jesse weight
episodes were made according to the
Russian version it focuses more on
real-life locations and situations could
it be just a coincidence or did the
director draw inspiration without even
realizing just how much of the concept
he actually copied will let you be the
judge
let us know what you think about these
knockoff shows in the comments and
that's all for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things and tell us how
you felt about this video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]